♪ Whoa, taking it all for us ♪
♪ ("ALL FOR US" BY ZENDAYA
AND LABRINTH PLAYS) ♪
ZENDAYA:
I got on the phone with Sam
after I watched the pilot.
He was like, "Yeah,
I want to do a musical number,
and it'll be beautiful,
and it'll be heartbreaking."
I was, you know, listening to
this Labrinth track "All for Us"
and there was something
that was so big
and triumphant and beautiful.
LABRINTH: Sam got that energy
from it, and was like,
this really feels like Rue.
And when he told me he wanted
to use it for a musical,
I was like, "Okay!"
I was like, "Bro, that's crazy."
♪ Doing it all for love ♪
ZENDAYA: Lab's a visionary,
and when he told me
that I would be able
to record it,
I was like, "Are you joking?!"
She listened to my version...
♪ Taking it all for us
All ♪
LABRINTH: She was like,
I'm not gonna do that,
but I'm gonna do my version.
♪ Taking it all for us all ♪
That's the perfect way
of approaching the music.
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
LABRINTH:
Sam came up with the idea
to add a marching band,
and an even bigger choir,
'cause we wanted to make sure
it was very massive.
Percussion came in,
and they did their parts.
(DRUMS BEATING)
And then we had
the woodwinds and the brass.
(WIND INSTRUMENTS PLAYING)
DON ROBERTS:
I'm watching Zendaya,
and I was watching her
watch the band,
and I could only
look at her reactions,
and I said, "Wow, she must
like that. It's pretty cool."
JEN MALONE:
The choir totally got into it.
They were connecting
with the song,
and they were having fun.
It just got bigger
and bigger and bigger.
SAM LEVINSON: Ryan Heffington
was our choreographer.
My job was to wrangle
200 people.
It's not always
just choreographing,
but it's also infusing
the scene with an importance.
LEVINSON: When I saw it
out in the streets,
I got that sorta pit
in my stomach of,
"Oh, we gotta do this justice."
Sam, of course,
came up with the most
elaborate scenario he could
to have this spectacular ending.
It was kinda conceived as
a bit of this death march.
It becomes sort of an extension
of what she's feeling.
The joy, the release,
the freedom that drugs bring.
And at the same time,
the real kind of horror.
-♪ Hey ♪
-♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
JULIO PEREZ:
Sometimes there's moments
where you're editing a scene
where you have this feeling
of like,
"Oh wow, this is going to be
genuinely, truly special.
ZENDAYA: While shooting,
everybody had such a good energy
and was so happy
and excited to be there.
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
ZENDAYA:
It felt very magical.
I think we all kinda went home
just like...
(SINGING)
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Doing it all for love ♪